- Medical sketches are
really like medical memes,
just reenacted.
And guess what?
On today's video, I'm
gonna be reacting some
of the most popular medical sketches
on YouTube, excluding SNL
'cause we've done those
already, link down below.
But first, I have a major
announcement for you.
I am looking to hire another editor.
We want you to join the team.
All the qualifications
and information is listed
down below in the description.
So if you think you're right for the job,
shoot me an email.
By the way, if you get this
video to 100,000 likes,
I might make a medical sketch of my own.
- Hello patient, I'm Dr. Edith Celburn.
- Hi Dr. Celburn.
(audience laughs)
- You're about to undergo an operation
to remove your appendix.
Just like this patient here,
you'll be under anesthesia
and completely unconscious.
- He doesn't look unconscious.
- Actually, I am still kind of conscious.
(audience laughs)
- I can fix that.
There we are, sleepy time.
- Why is the surgeon doing the anesthesia?
There should be an anesthesiologist
in the room monitoring the patient.
Lik a big function
of having an anesthesiologist present
is the fact that it allows the surgeon
to focus on the operation
and the anesthesiologist on
the sedation of the patient,
making sure that you're
not giving too much
where you're slowing down the
heart rate or the breathing.
Here, it looks like the
doctor just does everything.
- Now we make the incision right here.
(scalpel cracking)
- Why are there cracking noises?
Why is the mask not up?
Why is that happening right now?
- Oops, got a little leakage there.
(audience laughs)
- Leakage?
- In this case I've
made the incision bigger
so we have plenty of elbow
room to scoop out all the parts
of your insides that have gone bad.
Like this one.
And this one.
(audience laughing)
- Filled salamis?
- Not even sure what this is.
Oh well, out it goes.
Now we'll move some nasty
bones out of the way.
- What bones are in the
abdomen that you're taking out
when you're doing an appendectomy?
- Oh, looks like some of
these ribs won't budge.
Time for the bone saw.
- Ribs? The appendix is not that high up.
You're not going to the gallbladder.
You're not going for the liver.
You're going for the appendix.
It's lower. The ribs aren't in the way.
They don't need to budge.
And what kind of saw is that?
I just saw that.
You saw that pun?
Unintentional, but still delicious.
- We're losing him!
Prep a crash cart, give me 50-CCS...
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
(moans)
- First of all, chest compressions,
chest compressions, chest compressions.
If you're losing him and
you do not have a pulse,
this person is no longer living
and you need to begin CPR.
You don't start saying
you need CCS of anything.
You start doing chest compressions,
even while you're running.
Not like that.
- At first I thought the cause
of death was kidney failure
brought about by untreated diabetes,
but then I noticed the knife.
- Diabetes can absolutely
lead to kidney failure.
So can untreated high blood pressure.
A lot of people will
say, " Well I feel fine.
I don't feel the high blood pressure
so I must be okay."
It's a silent killer folks.
Hypertension can really
wreak havoc on your kidney
and your blood vessels and your heart,
which can lead to a stroke, heart attack,
congestive heart failure, so many issues.
- Okay, time to test those reflexes.
- (laughs) As a family medicine actor,
I see pediatric patients meaning children.
Seeing a child for the
first time is you need
to check their developmental milestones.
And I remember one of
the things I was trained
in my med school training was,
"Why don't you throw a block on the floor
and tell the child to retrieve it
and see if they're capable
of following instructions."
And I always felt uncomfortable
taking that advice
because I'm like, " What
am I gonna play fetch
with a child?"
Like, " Go get it!"
- Hi I'm Dr. Web MD.
So what brings you in here today?
- Well you're free.
- Too embarrassed to see a real doctor?
- You got me.
What is it doc?
- You have cancer.
- How could you possibly know that?
- Oh I tell everyone they have cancer.
- (laughs) I understand why doing this
in the middle of the night quickly,
in the privacy of your
own home is so appealing.
But the reality of the fact is,
it's almost always gonna be inaccurate.
Look don't get me wrong.
Web MD does a great job
at explaining a whole host
of range of conditions
so that you understand
when you do get a diagnosis
what do you actually have.
Or perhaps how to ask better questions
of your doctor/nurse,
whoever you're gonna go see.
But a lot of times when you
do the symptom tracker thing,
it just tells you you have cancer.
- What if I just say my shin hurts?
- See, told you cancer.
- I really don't think I have cancer.
- Nobody ever thinks they have cancer.
The symptoms can take
many different forms,
such as throbbing in head, runny nose,
mild cough, stress.
- Why was stove burn on that list?
Why does stove burn mean cancer?
- I'm gonna write you a prescription,
for 10 tips on how to
have a healthy summer.
Don't forget to bring a beach ball.
- (laughs) I feel like
there are articles like that
that keeps getting popped
up and recommended to you
alongside the little
pharma ads here and there.
So this is quite accurate thus far.
- I really think that you
should use some Zanoplax.
You just take a small dab,
rub it on your belly.
- Enough with the Zanoplax!
- Sorry about that.
They're one of my sponsors.
- You know what? I'm leaving.
- And who are you gonna see?
You don't have health insurance.
- I know everyone wants
to create an AI platform
where you type in some symptoms
and it spits out a diagnosis.
Medicine is complicated.
Medicine is subjective.
Symptoms are subjective.
Pain levels are subjective.
The way people understand medical
terminology is subjective.
So you just need a human being there.
I don't see humans ever
not taking care of humans.
But at the same time,
(robotic beeping)
there are robots among us.
(robotic tone)
So speak to your doctor about any symptoms
that you may be having and have
a good primary care doctor.
- [Narrator] The Anderson
twins have shared a lung
for 25 years.
Separating conjoined twins
is the most complicated medical procedure
we will ever perform.
- I have actually heard, I
don't know if this is accurate,
I could be spreading misinformation.
Someone needs to fact check me on this.
Doing a full head transplant
could be the hardest operation.
See if that's the case.
- This procedure will take
between 19 and 23 hours.
If Dr. Alexander will
note the time, we will be-
- All right chums, let's do this!
Leeroy Jenkins!
- No, no, no!
(laughs)
- I do understand the reference!
That's " World of Warcraft."
- [Cameraman] Yes.
- Oh my God I remember it.
And then they all ran in
and they all ended up dying.
- [Game Voice] Leeroy Jenkins!
- God what a throwback.
I used to love " WoW."
It ate so much of my time in high school,
it's kind of ridiculous.
- Okay, let me ask you a few questions.
Have you ever uttered the
phrase, "Get off my lawn?"
- No.
- Okay.
- I mean, yeah I've said.
But I didn't mean like old man,
like " Get off my lawn!"
I meant more like, "This is my
property so get off my lawn."
- I'm not gonna sugarcoat this for you.
You have Early Onset Grumpiness.
(ominous music)
- What?
- Early Onset Grumpiness, EOG.
You're gonna begin to enjoy fewer
and fewer things in your life.
You'll be saying things like,
" Who are these people?"
- Who are those people?
That's the thing, I mean
it's a real question.
- The only reason you leave the house
is to see classic old movies
and even then you'll say,
" It had some good parts
but all in all it was fairly..."
- Uneven.
(sighs)
- You're very young to have EOG.
Your life is gonna change forever.
- What would be the treatment
for Early Onset Grumpiness?
Joy, fun, therapy.
Maybe I'm doing a little stretch here.
There is something called
dysthymia in medicine.
Where you just in general for
an extended period of time,
have a low mood, like a depressed mood
but you don't have major
depressive disorder,
where you're just kinda down.
Maybe dysthymias can be
nicknamed Early Onset Grumpiness.
Just putting it out there.
This looks like it's like the 80s.
I'm getting an 80s vibe.
Ooh, why would you hit the
patient's head like that?
- Still something missing man.
- Hmm, hmm.
- [Both] Patient!
- Are they doing a C-section?
If they are, why are they not scrubbed in?
Why are they putting
on non-sterile gloves?
I have so many questions.
I don't know what all this technology is.
This is stuff from the 80s,
I wasn't around back then.
I was only born pretty much
in the last month of the 80's.
- Can I put the tube in the baby's head?
- Only if I can do the episiotomy.
- Okay.
- Very good, legs up.
You can come in, come on in all of you.
That's it, jolly good, come on.
- We do not do that.
- I'm the husband.
- I'm sorry, only people
involved are allowed in here.
- We do not just invite a peanut gallery
to watch a delivery.
Actually nurses probably
do the best job at this,
at managing who comes
in and out of the room.
When I was a medical student,
we actually trained to
first introduce ourselves
to the patient,
then once the patient
was comfortable with us,
we then introduced ourselves
to the nursing staff
to make sure that the
nurse can help teach us,
guide us, because they know so much more
than we do at that given moment.
And probably throughout
their careers as well.
- That's the machine that goes bing.
(machine binging)
You see that means your
baby is still alive.
- Oh the vulva is dilating doctor.
- Oh yes there is the head.
It has four centimeters,
five, six centimeters.
- Lights!
- You can't judge the
cervical dilation visually,
you need to be hands-on with this exam
and actually do a digital exam.
From there you can get an estimate
of what exactly the dilation is.
If the baby's head is already
visible, you're fully dilated.
You don't need four
centimeters measurements.
Like it doesn't make sense.
- And frightening!
(baby crying)
There, bring the rough towels!
- We do not have butcher knives,
so much wrong with this.
- There is the mother.
That's enough. Right sedate her.
- Hi, I'm here for my annual physical.
I haven't been in years
because I didn't have health insurance.
- Great. Fill out this stack of paperwork
that you know none of the
information for and wait an hour
after your scheduled
appointment to be seen.
- The reason this happens
is because medicine is unpredictable.
We don't know what's gonna happen
when a patient walks into our room.
Sometimes a patient
says that their problem
is in knee and then we
start questioning them
and we find out they're
having a heart attack.
That literally happened to me.
I'm linking that story down below.
It started with foot pain,
became a heart attack,
calling 911 and all.
- I don't want to tear this paper
but I don't know why I give a
sh because it's just a paper.
- That paper is the bane of my existence.
Not only is it incredibly noisy,
anytime you do any kind of exam.
(imitating paper crinkling)
It's everywhere.
But then also like as a
patient, like rotates and flips
and when I'm doing like
a leg exam or back exam,
or do some kind of OMT, it
wraps around the patient
and ends up trapping them and ripping.
Someone needs...
Elon Musk!
We need you!
Solve the paper problem.
Click here for my most favorite
medical meme review ever.
Like I really like this one.
I think you're gonna love it too.
So click for that bad boy.
And a little notice, if you get
this video to 100,000 likes,
I might make one of my
own medical sketches.
And I was an A-list actor
back in my seventh grade drama club days.
Just saying.
As always, stay happy and healthy.
Memes, click it.
(upbeat music)